The United Nations was founded 75 years agoto
save future generations from the scourge of war,
uphold human rights, and promote social
progress. The U.N. deserves credit for alleviating poverty,
promoting human rights, and brokering peace
treaties. But a rising China and a revanchist Russia
have been using the U.N. to promote their
own interests: shaping U.N. values and rules,
sometimes to the point of absurdity. Despite being
two of the leading countries responsible for human
rights violations, China and Russia have both just
been elected to the U.N.'s Human Rights Council.
The U.N. is one of many arenas in which
the Trump administration's isolationism
has allowed China and Russia to expand
influence in international politics.
China now leads four of 15 U.N. agencies, not to
mention its power over the WHO. To protect freedom
across the world, and to remain relevant, the U.N.
desperately needs to be reformed.
The US must not allow Russia and China to reform the world.
Do youthink that the United Nations should be reformed?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us knowwhat other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE andSUBSCRIBE
for more research and videos from AEI.